Talk to your doctor about XARELTO®.
There’s more to know™.
>> Laura: PRESIDENT TRUMP
DELIVERED A POWERFUL SPEECH AT
THE NATIONAL PRAYER BREAKFAST IN
WASHINGTON THIS MORNING.
HE EMPHASIZED OUR COUNTRIES KNOW
MY COUNTRY’S DEPENDENCE
ON GOD.
>> IN THE COURAGE OF OUR FELLOW
CITIZENS, WE SEE THE POWER OF
GOD’S LOVE AND THE POWER OF
GOD’S WILL TO ANSWER ALL OF OUR
PRAYERS.
WHEN AMERICANS ARE ABLE TO LIVE
BY THEIR CONVICTIONS TO SPEAK
OPENLY OF THEIR FAITH AND TO
TEACH THEIR CHILDREN WHAT IS
RIGHT, OUR FAMILIES THRIVE, OUR
COMMUNITIES FLOURISH, AND OUR
NATION CAN ACHIEVE ANYTHING AT
ALL.
>> Laura: TO THE SURPRISE OF
MANY, THE PRESIDENT, A MAN NOT
KNOWN FOR HIS FAITH BEFORE THE
ELECTION, HAS BECOME THE MOST
POWERFUL RELIGIOUS VOICE IN THE
PUBLIC ARENA.
TO REACT, WE ARE JOINED, FROM
NORTH CAROLINA, BUT EVANGELICAL
LEADER FRANKLIN GRAHAM.
IT IS SO GREAT TO SEE YOU,
FRANKLIN.
I THOUGHT THE PRESIDENT TODAY --
I THOUGHT HE WAS MESMERIZING.
DONALD TRUMP WAS THE GUY HOLDING
TORCH FOR GOD AND CHRISTIANITY,
JUDEO-CHRISTIAN CULTURE.
IT’S STUNNING.
>> IT IS STUNNING.
IN MY LIFETIME, I’VE NEVER HAD A
PRESIDENT LIKE THIS, AND HE’S
NOT AFRAID TO SPEAK OUT ABOUT
HIS FAITH.
THIS WAS THE 66TH PRAYER
BREAKFAST.
IT STARTED, MY FATHER ENCOURAGED
GOING BACK TO
PRESIDENT EISENHOWER AND OTHERS
WHO WORKED ON THIS AT THE VERY
BEGINNING, AND EVERY PRESIDENT
SINCE EISENHOWER HAS COME TO
THIS BREAKFAST, AND IT IS A
BIPARTISAN BREAKFAST PUT ON BY
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS.
THEY WORK TOGETHER.
THESE ARE MEN AND WOMEN OF FAITH
WHO COME TOGETHER IN A
BIPARTISAN WAY TO PUT ON THIS
BREAKFAST.
AND IT SHOWS YOU THAT WASHINGTON
CAN FUNCTION.
WE NEED MORE CHRISTIANS IN
WASHINGTON.
WE NEED MORE -- CAN YOU IMAGINE
IF THE MAJORITY OF THE HOUSE AND
SENATE WERE GOD-FEARING MEN AND
WOMEN?
THAT THEY COULD ARGUE THEIR
POINTS, BUT AT THE END OF THE
DAY, THEY WOULD COME TOGETHER
AND WORK FOR THE GOOD OF ALL
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WE NEED MEN AND WOMEN IN
WASHINGTON WHO BELIEVE IN GOD,
WHO BELIEVE IN HIS SON,
JESUS CHRIST, WHO TOOK OUR SIN
AND MEXICANS TO THE CROSS AND
GOT RAISED, WE NEED MORE MEN AND
WOMEN LIKE THIS.
LAST YEAR, I WENT ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY TO EVERY STATE CAPITAL
ASKING PEOPLE TO PRAY FOR THIS
COUNTRY AND ENCOURAGING
CHRISTIANS TO RUN.
AND I DIDN’T TELL THEM WHAT
PARTY TO RUN FOR.
THEY CAN BE REPUBLICANS.
BUT WE NEED CHRISTIANS AT EVERY
LEVEL OF GOVERNMENT, AND WHEN
CHRISTIANS COME TOGETHER, THIS
IS WHAT YOU SEE AT THE PRAYER
BREAKFAST.
THEY COME TOGETHER AND THEY WORK
TOGETHER.
I WAS GLAD TO BE THERE.
>> Laura: AT ONE POINT THE
PRESIDENT TALKED ABOUT HOW A
YEAR EARLIER HE HAD ASKED FOR
PRAYERS FOR, I BELIEVE IT WAS A
LITTLE GIRL WHO WAS VERY, VERY
ILL, AND HE SAID, HE WAS
OVERWHELMED BY THE RESPONSE, THE
PRAYER, REPORTED SHE WAS DOING
MUCH BETTER.
THAT WAS A SMALL MOMENT.
I PERSONALLY, I FELT THE POWER
OF PRAYER AT VERY DIFFICULT
TIMES.
THE LEFT DOESN’T UNDERSTAND
THAT, FRANKLIN.
THEY SAY, HE’S BEEN MARRIED ALL
THESE TIMES, HE CAN HAVE A FOUL
MOUTH, HOW CAN THIS FLAWED MAN
BE THIS EVANGELICAL AND CATHOLIC
LEADER IN A WAY?
HOOK DOES THAT HAPPEN?
HOW DOES GOD USE PEOPLE LIKE
THAT?
AND YOUR RESPONSE WOULD BE?
>> DONALD TRUMP IS NOT A PERFECT
PERSON.
I CERTAINLY, I’M NOT A PERFECT
PERSON, AND I WOULD HATE FOR
SOMEBODY TO HOLD ME UP AS BEING
THE GREATEST EXAMPLE OF THE
CHRISTIAN FAITH TO MAKE FAITH OR
CHRISTIAN LIFE.
I’VE GOT MANY FAILURES IN MY
LIFE AND SODAS DONALD TRUMP, BUT
THAT DOESN’T STOP ME FROM
BELIEVING IN GOD AND BELIEVING
IN HIS SON JESUS IN, , AND I
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT HE
DOESN’T RUN AWAY FROM HIS FAITH
AND HE’S WILLING TO STAND UP IN
FRONT OF THE WHOLE WORLD AND LET
THE WORLD KNOW WHERE HE STANDS,
AND HE APPRECIATES PEOPLE
PRAYING FOR HIM.
WE NEED TO PRAY.
WE ARE COMMANDED TO PRAY FOR ALL
OF THOSE, ALL OF THEM.
WHEN DONALD TRUMP WON THE
PRESIDENCY, HE BECAME YOUR
PRESIDENT AND MY PRESIDENCY, AND